FEMALE SPEAKER: Welcome and
thank you so much for being
with us here at Google.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: Thanks
for having us.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Absolutely.
Now, Brett you have a couple of
frag films to actually show
us before we started
the interview.
And I believe we're starting
with frag 10.
Tell us a little bit
about this frag.
BRETT LEONARD: Well, what a
frag film is, we have this
idea called PopFictionLife,
which is a way of making
musical movies that can be
distributed through the internet.
But there's still cinema.
They're not webisodes.
They're not episodic
in that sense.
It's still independent cinema.
So it's really a feature film.
But when you're doing
independent cinema these days,
and you don't have Tom Cruise or
giant movie stars in them--
not to say that you guys aren't
giant movie stars.
You're music stars.
But you have to seduce the
audience to get them to get
into the thing.
So we create what I call
frags, or fragments.
And we give away half the
movie with fragments--
with these frags.
You don't get all the story.
You don't get all the music.
So if you like it, and you want
to see the whole film,
actually this Sunday, December
9, we've been releasing the
frags over the past
several months.
We're going to be releasing
the entire film for $5
following the example of Louis
CK, who did, I think, an
amazing thing of getting direct
to the consumer with a
price point that makes sense
for independent content.
And if you just want to
watch half of it for
free, that's fine.
Because it's really about not
forcing it down people's
throats, not doing the
vertically integrated
corporate marketing that
works with mega-movies.
And what this allows, is it
allows you to do something
that is a little more
creatively free.
Every film in Hollywood now
has to have someone with a
cape or a cowl or something
like that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Nothing
wrong with that.
BRETT LEONARD: And there's
nothing wrong with that.
I go see those with my son, and
I absolutely love them.
But that's about--
THEODORE PAGANO: We tried
to get capes but he
wouldn't have it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I can have
a cape so we're good.
BRETT LEONARD: So I
always wanted to--
in the past, I've done science
fiction thriller films--
but I love music, and I
wanted to make a rock
and roll road picture.
And so when it came to that, I
was looking around for a band
and I heard they're called
Burlap to Cashmere and there's
a song on it called
The Other County.
And I just instantly saw this
movie in my head when I was
listening to it.
Then I met the guys and being
characters as they are and
tremendous live musicians, I
thought we had a chance to do
something where we could
actually record all the music
when we were doing
the film live.
So there's no overdubbing.
There's no post-syncing done
here at all in the film.
And they could play essentially
versions of
themselves.
And so when you see this first
frag, Frag 10, which is
literally being released today
for the first time--
we've been releasing them every
Thursday over the past
several months--
they're doing a scene that has
dramatic import to it.
And there's some
truth in there.
There's some fiction in there.
But you're not quite sure
which one it is.
It actually goes back to the
style of Italian neo-realism
more, the films of
John Cassavetes.
Why don't we just watch Frag 10,
and then we can talk about
it from there.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Let's
watch Frag 10.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
THEODORE PAGANO: Why do I get
a guilt trip for this?
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: Ted,
you called once.
THEODORE PAGANO: Yeah, when
you got out of hospital.
Did you want me to call you
while you're in the hospital?
The thing about calling people
when they're in a coma, John,
it's not exactly stimulating
conversation.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Ted,
he's got a point.
THEODORE PAGANO: I don't
think he has a point.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: You should at
least pick up the phone or
[INAUDIBLE].
THEODORE PAGANO: This is not
for me to [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: Ted, you and
I were in Brazil together
playing for 80,000 people and
then poof, you're gone.
THEODORE PAGANO: Yeah, and
then it ended John.
Everything ends.
No poof-- it's not like
I broke the band up.
We broke up, and I got
in with my life.
What did you want?
Why is this being
pinned on me?
Why are I at fault for this?
Blame Marcus.
He's the one who
tore us apart.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Marcus?
Come on.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: Steve.
THEODORE PAGANO: Come on what?
You're always sticking
up for this guy?
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: I'll have to
agree with Teddy on that one.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Come
on, the guy's dead.
THEODORE PAGANO: So?
So?
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: Steve,
the guy's dead.
You stick up for him like he's
a saint because he's dead.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: I didn't
say he was a saint.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: God
rest his soul.
I mean, there was a time where
he was a friend to us but
mainly he was just
a street hustler.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Yeah, well
we probably need a street
hustler again if we
want to get this
thing back on the road.
And Marcus may [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: Someone
who's street
hustling his own clients.
THEODORE PAGANO: Come on,
he just wore us out.
We couldn't withstand that.
No band could.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: You don't
even know what Marcus gave us.
MARCUS: What did I say?
I booked you some more shows.
What is that, a crime?
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Yes.
MARCUS: Come on.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: We just
finished 124 nights.
MARCUS: I know.
It's all about the momentum.
You don't want to lose that.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Marcus,
we're fried.
MARCUS: I'll tell you what
I'm going to do.
We do the 18 shows on
the East coast.
I call them and tell them
we'll cancel the rest.
THEODORE PAGANO: You
remember this one?
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: Yeah.
THEODORE PAGANO: I remember
this one [INAUDIBLE].
MARCUS: Guys, can't you tell?
We are so close I can
taste it right now.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: You know
what I taste right now?
I don't want to say what
I taste right now.
MARCUS: Guys, listen to me.
Listen to me.
Basic instructions, climbing
the charts.
You're getting more and
more radio play.
You want to keep that moving.
You stop now and somebody's
going to come up behind you
and take your spot.
Trust me, I've seen it.
I've seen it, all right?
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Fine, we're
going to finish the tour.
MARCUS: You don't want
to do all this
hard work for nothing.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: We'll finish
the tour, but we're
taking a break after that.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: This is
a man who knows you
owe it to your fans.
MARCUS: All right?
Don't look so glum.
Come on, let a smile be
umbrella if you want a
mouthful of rain.
Hey Alex, it's Marcus.
How are you doing?
Good, good.
Yeah, yeah, it looks
like we're all set.
I can confirm all 30 dates.
No sweat.
All right baby.
See you in about a week?
Good, ciao.
OK.
Come on, first one in the van
get an Ihop breakfast on me.
What is with the long
faces, come on?
Now I'm the chauffeur?
Is that it?
Nobody's going to sit
in the front?
[FOLK MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: So tell us what
Frag 10 is all about?
BRETT LEONARD: It's a totally
fictional story about a
fictional manager
named Marcus.
And--
FEMALE SPEAKER: A weaselly
guy, isn't he?
BRETT LEONARD: And yet, in every
band, there's always
tensions and things
that happen.
There are little glimpses of
the truth in there but
obviously hyped and
fictionalized so that the
drama works.
And it allowed the guys
to pull from their own
experiences, which is in the
genre of neo-realism that's
something that you try to do.
And it's a really fun thing,
because you get an
authenticity that is there and
yet you're still playing with
a fictional story so you
can make it go where
you want it to go.
And one of the other things
with the whole genre of
PopFictionLife is we're
integrating music as narrative.
It really is taking the idea of
what music video has been
and become and blending it
into narrative even more
organically.
And I just love music as the
inspiration for cinema,
because really for me, the
most pure cinema is just
picture and music.
And so this is sort of like a
dream come true for me to
create something that
had a musical story.
And the emotions, you don't have
to necessarily have a lot
of dramatic scenes to
convey the emotions
because the music does.
And of course these guys are
such great musicians and are
able to play their instruments
live and do it real that it
give it that authenticity.
I think that in internet content
in general, people are
looking for authenticity.
They're looking for something
that's more real, as opposed
to what you should get from
traditional Hollywood
entertainment.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Is that when you
chose to work with music
in particular for these
frag films?
BRETT LEONARD: Yeah.
It goes back also to the films
of Hal Ashby of the '70s.
If you think of Harold and
Maude, that was basically a
Cat Stevens album
put to a story.
Now would you think that Cat
Stevens would be able to carry
a story about a suicidal
teenager who has a love affair
with an 83-year-old woman?
Meaning, music and narrative
and cinema can do anything.
They can create any combination
of things and
actually work.
And so it allows me that
freedom as a filmmaker.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do you plan on
keeping your frag films within
the musical realm?
BRETT LEONARD: PopFictionLife
itself, yes.
But we're going to be expanding
the genre to
incorporate other kinds
of subject matter.
But I always probably will want
to incorporate music,
because you wouldn't necessarily
always have to
have a band starring in
a PopFictionLife film.
This is a unique situation,
because I thought these guys
would be great at doing that.
We had a lot of fun doing it.
So it was an opportunity to do
something that can combine.
Those things came together
just perfectly.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We also
have Frag 11 to show.
And that one actually
hasn't aired yet.
It hasn't come out yet.
BRETT LEONARD: Yeah.
The Frag 10 just
came out today.
And Frag 11 is going to be
coming out Sunday when the
entire film is available on
PopFictionLife.com for that $5 purchase.
If people like all
the 11 frags--
FEMALE SPEAKER: And then they
can get the whole film.
BRETT LEONARD: And then you
could get the whole film where
you see how the story
turns out.
So at the end of this frag is
where actually the three frags
end, meaning like a cliffhanger
of what's going to
happen in the story.
And then to see the third act
and all the other pieces of
the story, you get the
full feature film.
So this Frag 11.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: I've called
you like eight times.
Where have you been?
THEODORE PAGANO: What do
mean where have I been?
I'm working.
I'm out on the road here.
I've been making calls
constantly.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: I understand
that you're working.
But also understand that I'm
trying to get hold of you.
If you've got time to call other
people, then you've got
time to get back to me.
THEODORE PAGANO: No, because I
don't sit by the phone and
wait for you to call all day.
I don't have the time to.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: I'm
not asking you
to sit by the phone.
I'm just asking you to
send me one text.
You're being really unreasonable
about this.
THEODORE PAGANO: Look,
if I don't do this,
it doesn't get done.
So I have to.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Well maybe
if you don't have time, I
don't have time.
I'll just leave my phone
here, and I'll go out.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS:
[INAUDIBLE].
THEODORE PAGANO: Oh, really?
Wonderful.
Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: I'm going.
THEODORE PAGANO: Fine.
[ROCK MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: Now what?
MALE SPEAKER: Busted a hose.
It'll take a little while
until I can fix it.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: Great.
THEODORE PAGANO: Guys, we've
got to be at this funeral
service in a few hours.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: Ted, we're
going to be there just fine.
THEODORE PAGANO: What do
you mean [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: At this point,
who cares about the
funeral service?
Really?
THEODORE PAGANO: What are
we here for then?
What didn't we just stay home?
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: I didn't
have a choice
in the matter, Ted.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Why didn't
you have a choice in the
matter John?
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: Steve.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: What?
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: I love you.
You're my cousin.
We're standing out in the middle
of the desert baking in
the sun right now with a
broken down vehicle.
THEODORE PAGANO: What do you
think we owe this guy?
We don't owe him anything.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Marcus?
THEODORE PAGANO: Yes, Marcus.
We don't owe him anything.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: We owe
Marcus everything, Ted.
FEMALE SPEAKER: A
lot of tension
going on in that frag--
all sorts of trouble
on the horizon.
BRETT LEONARD: Yeah.
The film is about them traveling
from Brooklyn to Los
Angeles for the funeral
of their ex-manager.
And the drama is around what
that ex-manager did and didn't
do for them, how they each feel
about him, and how they
feel about each other.
And it all comes down in the
third act, at the funeral.
There's also a few
romantic glimmers
along the way, as well.
But it's really in a sense, a
gentle story that goes with
the feeling of the music.
This is something that really
starts with the music for me
in terms of what that is.
And then we all met together.
And one of the aspects of this
you had mentioned, we were
showing it the colors, I
really wanted to create
something that had the look
and feel of a '70s movie.
The band had asked for that
when we first met.
And I was like, instantly
yes, let's do that.
Because HD, with the new cameras
we can do so many
interesting things with
available light
cinematography, and then
post-process with grain and do
very creative things that
you weren't able
to do in the past.
And so we celebrated that in
this film, utilizing those
kinds of looks and feels to
give it a different feel.
So it's its own genre,
in a sense.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I want to talk
a little bit about what
PopFictionLife is and how
the frag film fits
into that new brand.
And then we'll get back to the
band and music itself.
Tell us what PopFictionLife
is and what
it offers the consumer.
BRETT LEONARD: It's really
a way of creating and
distributing independent cinema
in a way that realizes
the reality of getting direct to
consumer, not going through
the distribution apparatus.
I mean, I worked in Hollywood
for over 25 years as a
director and producer.
And the business models of
Hollywood have changed
significantly in that time.
And primarily, especially for
most independent cinema, it's
very, very dysfunctional.
You have a very narrow sort of
window through which most
things get distributed and
how they distributed.
And there really is no reason
for that now that we're all
connected in the way we are.
So for people that want to
find different kinds of
content, it can still be very
high quality content.
It doesn't always have to just
be cats falling out of trees.
And I think we're leaving that
era of internet content and
moving into much higher
quality content.
Across the board, there's a lot
of people doing that now.
But PopFictionLife is
specifically designed to also
allow the idea of frags or being
able to absorb content
through fragments, because it
started for me watching my
young son and how he looked
at films and content.
It's an ADD generation--
there's an ADD aspect to
our culture going on.
And people sometimes
will go just watch
one scene of a movie.
Now, that's not me.
I like to go watch the four hour
version of Lawrence of
Arabia once a year, because
I just love that kind of
cinematic experience.
But that's not really where the
entire culture is going.
And so in recognizing that,
fragmenting story.
You could even watch these
frags out of order.
You can watch them in any way.
You could watch one or two, and
then get excited about the
story, then go get
the whole film.
So we're trying to giving the
digital content consumer a
greater choice in how
they absorb content.
And also, one of the biggest
things we're going to be
doing, my partner Christopher
[? Creber ?]
is heading up the interactive
side of PopFictionLife.
And frags are designed to
create interactivity.
If you look at some of the stuff
that's happened here
Google with Chris Milk and what
he did with Arcade Fire.
Frags are designed to have
interactivity with them and
yet still maintain the integrity
of being a full
independent feature film.
FEMALE SPEAKER: How
does that work?
How does the interactivity
between the users work?
BRETT LEONARD: Well that's
a big question, isn't it?
That's what everyone's trying
to figure out these days.
I think one, obviously
integration into social media,
which we're doing a lot
of is very important.
So that people can discuss
and talk about things.
It's also about showing how this
kind of content can be
made, because it can be made
very, very, very cost
effectively and yet
at a high quality.
And all the tools are coming
down to really a generation
that I believe is going to
be communicating through
cinematic language
much more than
almost any other language.
And in a sense, cinematic
language is a global language.
And so by doing these kinds of
projects, using the expertise
of Hollywood filmmaking, but
sort of doing it in the same
way that a lot of very young
filmmakers out there.
I basically mentor and employ
a lot of young filmmakers to
make these films.
Because the way they are
integrating with the tools,
the way they think about
cinema, is completely
different than my generation.
And it's very exciting to me,
because I think it's about the
march of cinematic language
moving forward and becoming
truly interactive.
Gaming is obviously becoming
more and more cinematic and
yet is very interactive.
I think there's so many more
places to go with that that
aren't just in these narrow
areas that are
happening right now.
And you can do interactivity
with emotions.
You can do interactivity
with the way in
which you create something.
That alone and integrating with
a community of people
that are making content with
tools that allow them to make
it compelling.
Because it is a language.
It's not just an art
form at this point.
Every language started as an
art form and then became
something more consistent
as a language over time.
If you look at the printing
press, if you look at
calligraphy, all the things that
have developed over the
ages, and so I think cinema
is that global language.
And I happen to believe that
cinematic language has a great
hope to it, because it
translates across all barriers.
And so if you can teach people
how to create compelling
cinematic language and also get
it out there in a way that
can truly find its audience,
there's great things that can
happen there.
We've obviously seen certain
things like, Facebook movies
and things that are showing that
this is something that's
really developing in the
global mind frame.
And it's an exciting time.
So this is a reaction.
PopFictionLife is a reaction
to all that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's also very
interactive for sponsors and
advertisers.
How does that work so that it
doesn't detract the viewer
from the film itself?
BRETT LEONARD: Well I think
pre-roles and all that, we're
in this first stage of
internet advertising.
And I think that truly more
integrated advertising or
sponsorship that doesn't impinge
on the integrity of
what the content is is becoming
more and more the
norm, because that's what
the consumer wants.
That's what the people want.
The generation that consumes
internet content doesn't like
it to be slapped
in their face.
And yet there's a lot of
competing forces in that.
There's no one answer to
any of these things
you're talking about.
One of things that we talk about
with PopFictionLife--
it's a fluid, digital company,
meaning we are reacting to
what's happening out there.
And the one thing I know is
how to create a cinematic
story, and how to do that in a
compelling way, and how to
make it look good.
So by creating things as cost
effectively as possible,
getting them out there without
a middleman, and empowering
the consumer, and then
also the creator.
Content creators and consumers
who are becoming one in the
same thing.
There's a lot of
entrepreneurial
opportunities in that.
I think that sponsors and
advertisers are starting to
recognize that.
Although they move slower than
you would possibly imagine.
FEMALE SPEAKER: But wouldn't
most of the funding
be coming from them?
And so they're obviously really
important to the process.
BRETT LEONARD: We've raised our
own money to fund these
initially, because again, we're
just trying to create an
entire package of this
is the idea.
And then we've had interest from
a number of sponsors and
advertisers that say, hey, this
is something if you've
got someone like this kind
of name to do this.
And obviously, larger mega-acts
or things like that
would drive that more.
But I think that there's ways of
doing this without it being
driven just by three
or four names.
I think that this is something
that can fragment out, so to
speak, in a much more
diffused manner.
FEMALE SPEAKER: In terms of
marketing, you call those
diffuse distribution
versus vertical.
What exactly does it mean
and how does it work
in different markets?
BRETT LEONARD: Well, because we
parse things in frags, it
gives us the opportunity
to do them in all kinds
of different ways.
The interesting thing about
the internet in terms of
distributing independent cinema
too is it's not like
it's there in your local theater
for a weekend and
you've got to go see it.
It's once it's there,
the local theater is
there all the time.
So we can then release these
frags in different ways--
do contests around frags, do
things that talk about, do you
like to look at this one.
How do we do that?
Bore down and drill down into
deeper interactivity with the
content creators that
are out of there
that are also consumers.
So this is all stuff that we're
developing right now.
We wanted to start by making a
frag film that was compelling
and for a broad audience,
and that's what The
Other Country is.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So now, you guys
as a band have a really
interesting story.
You had a successful debut album
and then you disappeared
for 10 years.
And now you're back with
a self-titled album.
What encouraged you
guys to come back
and get back together?
And what were you able to bring
to this record after a
10 year hiatus?
THEODORE PAGANO:
What encouraged
us to get back together?
We always all did music.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS:
Yoga, I think--
THEODORE PAGANO: Yeah.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Helped
homelessness.
When you walk into a Starbucks,
and you saw an
application for a job, then you
think maybe we should--
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: Steven and
I are cousins, and so we've
always played together.
And that never ended.
And Teddy was out in the
UK for a little bit.
So I think what the inspiration
really was just we
had done it.
We had had some success.
But there were definitely things
that we wanted to do
that we never did then, because
we were too green and
inexperienced.
And so there is definitely
a fire under all
of us to do it again.
The question was, were we
actually going to do.
And a few different situations
led us all to getting back
together again.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Teddy
was living in England--
the drummer--
and he came back.
Me and Johnny were playing
music continuously.
And I had written
all the songs.
We have the songs.
We had most of them.
We had a basement to start
rehearsing and a manager and a
label that was interested
in signing us.
And we just went for it.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: We sort of
went backwards, because we had
some success and then came back
to just almost starting
over again.
Teddy thought that we might
score another deal, but Steven
and I were just like,
we're old.
Who's going to sign us again?
We were picked up
by Sony Jive.
It was almost like lightning
striking twice.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Once we hit
19, it was like, it's over.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS:
It's over, yeah.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: It's all
downhill from here.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS:
Yeah, exactly.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Now how did
you get meet with Brett?
How did this all come about?
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Our manager
knew Brett's partner and we
all met in LA at a really
cool diner.
What was the diner called?
BRETT LEONARD: Jerry's Deli.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Jerry's
Deli, yeah.
It's really, really
good actually.
THEODORE PAGANO: It's just
a little cool diner.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: And we sat
down with Brett and just had a
conversation.
And we actually were all
a little starstruck.
We knew who he was, and were
very excited to meet him, and
dumbfounded why he was
talking to us.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Brett, why were
you talking to you guys?
BRETT LEONARD: I listened
to the album.
I didn't want to choose who I
was doing this first frag film
with based upon anything but
just responding to the music
and responding to who
the people are.
Because that's one of the things
that just drives me
crazy, the hierarchy of how
content happens it isn't a
true meritocracy.
And so I just want to
respond to that.
I love the album.
And I just saw, wow, I could
make a movie from this.
And they're so authentic in the
fact, when I went and saw
them after we met and saw them
perform live the first time,
that I was truly hooked.
Because I wanted to do something
where you didn't
have to, in a sense, fake
the music in any
way, shape or form.
And there's not one moment of
fake music in this movie.
It's purely capturing them in
their live performance, which
is truly wonderful.
They're very virtuosic in
they're performance.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And it's very
unique to have completely live
music in a film.
Was that liberating
for you guys?
Or was that difficult?
Were you worried that there's
no post-production?
THEODORE PAGANO: No.
That's the type of
band that we are.
We don't use electronics.
We're very much like
a '70s folk band.
We get together to play.
We have chemistry
with each other.
And that's our thing.
So it's quite natural for us.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So it was kind
of liberating for you guys.
It was just all natural.
THEODORE PAGANO: Yeah.
We just did our thing.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: It was
actually nice, because the
record that Brett heard
was all recorded--
Pro-tools was used as the
medium just because it's
cheaper to capture it there.
But the computer screen was
not allowed in the room.
There was no auto-tuning
and no editing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Which is so
cool and completely unique
these day, I feel like.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: There
was no nudging.
Yeah.
It was just live.
And the fact that they were
going to capture it that way,
that's all we know
how to do anyway.
So post-production to us
is not really even a--
BRETT LEONARD: Burlap to
Cashmere for me, was a band
that deserved to have
a movie made.
And I just wanted that to be the
reason, because we're not
spending millions of dollars
doing these.
We're spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars, but
we're not spending millions
of dollars.
So there's a liberating
aspect to that.
And independent cinema used
to be about that.
It used to be about doing
something truly authentic.
As I mentioned John Cassavetes,
he's one of my heroes.
And if you go back and see the
things he talked about, about
what drove him to make the
cinema he did, that is me
returning to those roots.
Even though I hadn't done these
kinds of films before, I
had done films that were much
more visual effect oriented
and all that.
So really for me, it was a
liberating experience from
doing a different
kind of cinema.
And because they're so
authentic, and then they were
able to play versions of
themselves very authentically,
it was again, this great
confluence of things.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And a very
unique experienced for
everyone, I'm sure.
Now, guys, when you first heard
about the frag film
concept, what was
your reaction?
How did you feel that it would
assist musicians or the music
genre in general?
THEODORE PAGANO: We struggled to
understand it at first and
I think a lot of people do.
The idea of it a manager said,
so we have this on Friday, and
then there's this, and then, oh
we might be making a movie.
We're like, what.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS:
Pass the salt.
THEODORE PAGANO: So he tried
to explain it as best as he
could, but we didn't really
understand it until we met
with Brett and he
explained it.
BRETT LEONARD: That's one of the
reasons I just went ahead
and made the film.
Because I wanted to show, until
we have all the frags
out there and then we release
the film, now everyone's
starting to get it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's easier
to wrap your head around.
BRETT LEONARD: People were
going, oh I see.
Oh, you're giving it
away for free.
All of those ideas are counter
to the way in which Hollywood
cinema distribution has worked
for forever that it's new.
But that for me, is
why I get up.
That's what drives me is to do
something new and different
that can empower both people
that watch films and also
people that make them.
FEMALE SPEAKER: My first
question when I started doing
the research was, how does it
differ from a trailer or a
teaser for a film?
BRETT LEONARD: Essentially, it's
making the film be a lot
of teasers, a lot of trailers.
And you're seeing this
happen in bigger
studio films, as well.
You're seeing secondary material
being put out before
big films like Prometheus,
things that are put out as--
FEMALE SPEAKER: People
want [? even more. ?]
BRETT LEONARD: Yeah.
They want [? even more. ?]
And so this is a way of doing
it with more independent
cinema and giving away even more
so that if you like it,
then it's authentic that
you want to buy it.
It's not like, to see that
big movie I've got to
spend $19.95 on iTunes.
And I think that's not going to
be the way that independent
cinema works in the future.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What is the
overall theme of this
particular film?
What is the message?
BRETT LEONARD: Well again, it
comes out of the music for me.
I'm sure that the musicians
themselves would have a more
deep answer in terms of where
the music comes from.
But for me, it was about
this journey.
And so we created a journey,
in a sense.
But Steven could probably speak
to that better than me.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Brett
had it right.
I think when Brett wanted to do
the project first, it was
about The Other Country.
It was about the other side.
And I believe we had a
conversation about close
family or friends who
had passed on, and
that was our bond.
And I think the film really was
inspired and like, well,
what happens to those people
that you love and that are so
close to you and you lose them,
and they die, or they
leave and this and that.
And so The Other Country was
this antidote to that reality
that as human beings, we all
have to go through and face.
And I think Brett was really,
really keen on making that the
focal point in the film.
When I wrote the music, the
lyrics were the focal point of
I see the other country, just
basically like, it's the
ultimate near death experience
record, hopefully.
And I think Brett got
that and wanted to
capture it, and he did.
BRETT LEONARD: And I think
because we made it a journey
across this country, and we've
been in a lot of interesting
foment in this country lately.
There's a bit of for me, also a
political angle there that's
expressed in purely
the visuals.
It's not something that we
put in the narrative.
It's purely expressed in
the cinematic language.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What is it?
BRETT LEONARD: Well, just that
there's more than one America.
And even moreso now than
ever we see that.
But if you go back and you watch
Lincoln, you'll see it's
been that way for
very long time.
And so for me, all those themes
that were more mystical
in nature also reflect in the
overall geography and nature
of this country.
And I've traveled across
the country.
I hitchhiked across the country
when I was a teenager.
I love traveling America,
because it literally is like
traveling through multiple
countries.
And people from outside of here
see that even moreso than
people that come from here.
And so I wanted to express that
but not in an overhanded
way, just in a way that was
touched in inside the visual
language of the film.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I definitely
thought what you're saying
through some of the frags that
I watched on the website when
you guys are playing
in the club.
And it's a bunch of hillbillies
and at first they
don't know what's going on.
And you're like, oh great,
we've got to do this.
And then they totally
get the vibe.
So it was really interesting.
BRETT LEONARD: That frag
you're talking
about is frag two.
Those are real people.
For me, again, the neo-realism
format of going in and just
going into a bar literally
saying, we're going to buy
drinks for everybody.
Come on down.
Those are just real people
responding in a real way to
hear music as they played it.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: And Brett
literally would like just, OK.
And he'd leave us out in
a pit of scorpions.
And he'd be like, now react.
Oh, what the hell's going on?
BRETT LEONARD: It is
a dicey thing.
In the film, Johnny tells a
story that comes from a very
personal and traumatic
event of his life.
You only get to see that story
if you see the whole film.
But there's courage in doing a
film like this, because you
have to expose even more of
yourself as a performer.
So in a way, even though they're
primarily musicians,
as performers, as actors so to
speak, they had to expose
themselves greater than
most actors do in
a traditional film.
So there's a real frision
that takes place there.
And I think that's unique.
I think that authenticity is
something people can find and
respond to.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I agree.
I think this whole concept
is very unique.
And we discussed what it offers
the consumer as well as
the advertiser.
What about the independent
content creator?
What does the frag
film offer them?
BRETT LEONARD: Where we're
taking PopFictionLife is to
create a content creation
community that we're going to
get under the hood with how
we're creating these films,
because we're doing them very,
very differently than
traditional Hollywood
productions.
In fact, most Hollywood
production is utilizing the
methodology of 1935
production.
The forms, the way in which--
they shoot the show
Californication right next
door to me in Venice,
California.
And I love that show,
by the way.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's
a good show.
BRETT LEONARD: It's mostly
people talking in rooms or
doing something in rooms.
And it's 15 trucks,
200 people.
They're blowing up an anthill
with a nuclear bomb.
And its ridiculous that with
the technology we have for
image acquisition and post
production, that the way in
which Hollywood films are made
makes no logical sense to any
kind of true manufacturing
process.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Gotta do
something with the budget.
BRETT LEONARD: Well,
that's the thing.
That makes no sense to--
and sometimes, I'm like the
crazy hippie film director.
I'm going, I'm more conservative
than you guys
are, because you just want
to spend more money.
I don't understand
why, because you
get one less freedom.
You have to make everything
get dumbed down
to a certain degree.
And so to make films a very
different way, and in a sense,
I'm following my son Shannon,
who is turning 18 on the night
when this film was released.
And I started watching him
when he was about 10.
He started making content
himself, not
that I pushed him.
I didn't.
He just started doing it, and I
was like, boy, you're really
doing this differently.
And I realized, this
is the future.
And so I started going in that
direction with how I was
producing films.
And we're going to open
the coffers of that.
We're going to bring a community
together that's
doing that and create something
we call the
frag-plex, which is make your
own frags and market them
through this community
of people, as well.
So there's not just production,
but also
distribution and marketing all
in one open-sourced idea of
production and distribution.
Because again, as I said,
cinematic language is
something that needs to be more
broad based then just
about the things that Hollywood
makes about.
Again, there's nothing wrong
with big Hollywood movies.
I love them.
There's something greater
there to be explored.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Now for those
people that want to learn how
to make these frag films, where
do they go and learn?
Do they go to
PopFictionLife.com?
BRETT LEONARD: Yes.
We're going to start creating
a an overall community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Tutorials?
BRETT LEONARD: It's not
really tutorials.
It's more like open forums.
And it's giving them access
to my core group and then
extending out from there and
then finding other people that
have core competencies, because
there's so many people
that are super talented.
I mean, if you go on Vimeo and
look at some of the amazing
pieces that are on there.
There's so much talent
out there.
And there's only one tiny route
that some of that talent
gets to actually make
Hollywood films.
I happen to be a person that
pushed through that, because
I'm just a crazy,
tenacious dude.
But if you don't have that kind
of intense obsession,
you're not going to
necessarily get
your stuff out there.
And that to me, is a tragedy,
because I think there's so
much that can be expressed
through cinema that isn't.
And so PopFictionLife with its
interactivity, with utilizing
interactive technology that
allows you to connect with a
community of people, market with
a community of people,
and distribute it, and find out
what people respond to and
what they don't.
So it's in a sense, almost
like a Hollywood 2.0.
It's a different environment
to do content in.
And yet, it's still serious
content creation.
It's not just frivolous
FEMALE SPEAKER: Now, part
of the frag film--
a big part of it-- is the
cinematic quality.
And that's what you talk
about quite a bit.
Once you have all these other
people creating these frag
films, how do you control
the cinematic
quality at that point?
BRETT LEONARD: Well, you
don't control it.
Control is overrated.
There's a meritocracy that will
happen that is actually
very much an inherent part
of internet content.
Obviously, there's certain
aspects of internet content
that always will be the freak
show or something that just
grabs hold.
If people can find it and if
they can respond to it, then
that's what's going to
rise to the top.
And it's something that I think
we're moving through
this first phase as I said, of
internet content and moving
into a more mature phase.
It's still going to take time.
This is all very young and in
the beginning stages, but
that's what's exciting
about it.
Again, there's no rules.
We're not saying we know
every single answer.
As a matter of fact, that's one
of the strengths of what
the PopFictionLife
concept is about.
It's going to be very fluid.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What
is your dream?
How far do you see
the frag film,
PopFictionLife concept going?
What is the future of it?
BRETT LEONARD: It's
an organic thing.
I'm doing it, in a sense, like
I said, for my son--
for his generation of
content creators.
They have a different motivation
for making content.
I mean, when I grew up in
Toledo, Ohio, my motivation
was to get to Hollywood and
make big feature films.
That era is sort of changing.
Now that you're able to make
really high quality content
with cameras this big or our
phones, there were things in
that last frag that were all
shot with the iPhone.
And then we had to degrade them
to actually make them
look like the aesthetic
correlation with
the rest of the film.
It's just such an era where all
the cards have been thrown
in the air.
And so we're just trying to
take advantage of that, be
opportunistic, be
entrepreneurial, and provide
routes for other people.
Essentially, there's a mentoring
aspect to this.
As I get older, as a filmmaker,
I've gotten a lot
of my dreams as a filmmaker.
I want to mentor a larger group
of people to be able to
create their content, because
I really want to
see what gets created.
I love discovery.
And so that's really
want I'm doing for.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And I wanted to
ask all of you guys, what
do you think is the future of
digital and media film and
music industry in the
next 10 years?
What do you think is
going to happen?
THEODORE PAGANO: I think that's
a sub-topic of a whole
another Q&A.
JOHN PHILIPPIDIS: I think
personally that what Brett's
doing here is giving a chance to
some of the younger, maybe
frustrated artists out there who
would not get the ability
to ever score a Hollywood
picture film.
And with a lot of the bands that
I'm sure we all love, on
the music end of it, I'm sure
most of the bands that
everybody here loves did not
follow the mold to get
straight to a major
record company.
They just happened to
have been good.
So when you guys were talking
about controlling the content,
I think the whole concept is,
don't control the content.
Because that's how a lot of the
stuff that looks all the
same gets massed together
and we're just fed it.
And now we're stuck listening
to the same music, watching
the same movies, and that's why
every time a trailer comes
out, someone like me would
rather stay home than go to
see the flick, because nowadays
you don't know what
you're going to get
your hands on.
So I think that if the future
is heading this way, I would
hope that it happens in the
music industry as well.
Because as well as creating a
lot of people who maybe aren't
filmmakers or aren't musicians,
it will actually
give people the opportunity,
let's say who maybe never had
it before but should
be doing it.
BRETT LEONARD: I think
it's a trend.
I think there's an ache for
authenticity and an ache for
something--
we've been in a period
of deconstruction.
And everything is about
deconstructing what has been
the authentic stuff that
was and twist it, and
turn it, and do it.
But it's all the same.
I think there's so many new
things that could be created
if they were allowed a fertile
bed to be created.
This is just one idea to help
create some of that
fertility--
creative fertility.
I'm sure there will be
many, many others.
For me, it's not about ruling
the content world or
anything like that.
It's about allowing a group of
people to get larger in an
organic way that can create, and
distribute, and enjoy this
new kind of cinema.
And when I say cinema, I mean
music and cinema, really it's
all becoming one thing.
I think one of the things
I wanted to do with
PopFictionLife was bring back
the idea of the album
experience, which is, this is
a full album in this film.
And because you have a story
with emotion, you want to
listen to all the songs, because
they have context.
As opposed to just the, it's
got to be a single.
And there's nothing wrong
with a great single.
I love a great single
with a great hook.
And that's hard to do.
But an album experience is
also very worthwhile.
It goes back to when I was in
junior high and we listened to
Dark Side of the Moon--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Pink Floyd.
The Wall.
BRETT LEONARD: In a dark room
and I'll never forget that.
I think by adding in cinematic
language to that kind of
experience, everything
is a screen now.
Everything is a screen.
And those screens are
only multiplying.
And so the speakers are
this big, and the
screens are this big.
So you've got to create visual
content that goes with the
music that's not
just fashion--
what the music video is-- but
has actual true emotion and
human truth in it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And in closing,
for those that want
to follow the evolution of
PopFictionLife and the films
that you guys are offering,
PopFictionLife.com offers all
of the information
and the films.
BRETT LEONARD: That's right.
That's where you go.
And we have a Facebook page.
Go out there and like us.
There's a newsletter and
all the usual stuff.
And it's very much a
grassroots effort.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Guys, thank you
so much for being here.
I really appreciate it.
STEVEN DELOPOULOS: Thanks
for having us.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We're going to
open up the room for questions
if anybody has questions.
AUDIENCE: Can you give us some
examples of interactivity that
you experienced so far,
especially with in terms with
interacting with bands, which
I would imagine that
[INAUDIBLE]?
BRETT LEONARD: We haven't
incorporated much.
The only interactivity has been
social media interaction
at this point.
We want to utilize some of the
new technological things that
allow interactivity that can
connect with additional
material, second screen
experiences.
Obviously with different kinds
of music and different kinds
of subject matter,
there's other
opportunities that could come.
This piece is a very organic
piece that comes directly from
the organic nature of the
band and the music.
As I said, they play
the music live.
We didn't want to add on
interactivity on top of that
in a way that was inappropriate
to the vibe of
this particular piece.
So this really is the
kernel for which.
But I'm very, very interested
in interactivity.
My son, who's part of that and
Christopher [? Creaver ?],
who's heading that up,
their passion is
finding ways to interact.
We're developing some projects
that are more science fiction
based, things like that that
are going to have a genre
component to them that allows
much more interesting
interactivity.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Anybody else?
BRETT LEONARD: And if there's
anyone at Google that wants to
play with us, we're very
open to doing--
I love what Chris Milk did with
the Arcade Fire piece.
That was truly an emotional
use of interactivity.
And so those are the kinds of
things that interest me.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to ask
you about the filming style
that you used.
In some places, it was like an
Instagram video and you used
the saturated colors.
Why did you choose to do that?
BRETT LEONARD: Well, I
started doing HD--
I was one of the first people
to ever use HD--
years, and years,
and years ago.
So are the ability to post
process images, which
Instagram is a consumer
version of, is been
around for a while.
And that's a style I've been
developing with a lot of my HD
projects in different ways.
This was very specific--
using grain, using image
degradation, using those kinds
of things as a style.
We have a saying at [INAUDIBLE],
we'd push all the
buttons just to try everything
that exists
and see what works.
Because I think there can
be a celebration of
HD as its own aesthetic.
I love film, and film is
a tremendous aesthetic.
But HD is really a
different medium.
It's like oils and acrylics.
From a creative standpoint, I
think it could be pushed even
more in terms of doing things
that truly make it unique to
its own medium.
And so we're trying
to do that.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
using an iPhone?
What are some of the
other cameras?
BRETT LEONARD: 5D, 7D because
this was no permits, complete
guerrilla filmmaking.
We did a whole scene by they're
rehearsal basement in Brooklyn--
in the street of Brooklyn--
and suddenly there were all
these detectives around
walking down the street going in
canvas because some murder
that took place.
And we're shooting a movie in
the middle of that, and not
one of them batted an eye.
Because with the 5D and 7D, it
looks like you're shooting
skills, or whatever.
And so the freedom of that,
which is very again, much the
Cassavetes style and the
neo-realism style, it just
allows again, an authenticity
that you just can't get with a
different kind of
filming style.
There are new cameras
coming up.
Now, I would shoot a whole
one of these with
just the iPhone now.
These are great cameras.
Image acquisition is not the
issue at this point.
AUDIENCE: Also because you
weren't capturing sound.
BRETT LEONARD: We were
capturing sound.
AUDIENCE: You were capturing
sound on the iPhone?
BRETT LEONARD: No, not
on the iPhone.
We had separate sound.
We had separate sound,
defintely.
But the zoom--
as mobile and as lean as
possible to get the quality.
Again, it goes back
to expertise.
One of the things that we want
to share with people is with
these very, very simple tools,
if you have a certain
expertise, you can make things
that are just as high quality
as Hollywood does.
It's just about the expertise.
So you have to add
that layer in.
And that's one of things
PopFictionLife wants to do.
That's part of the interactivity
with the
community, because
there are tricks.
There's a lot of tricks that
you learn over the years.
I just I just love the freedom
that these kinds of cameras
and technologies allow.
And it really has to get back
to getting something
authentic, getting something
new, getting something that
you discover while you're
making a film.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Anybody else?
OK.
Well guys, thank you so
much for being here.
I think this is a very brilliant
concept and very
interesting.
And maybe I'll get involved.
BRETT LEONARD: Everybody go to
PopFictionLife.com, and check
out The Other Country
on December 9.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank
you guys.
BRETT LEONARD: Thank you.